welcome to the USMLE revision playlist
in this video we'll talk about b-cell
activation this is a high yield concept
and it would take very less time but it
would be highly informative
b-cell activation starts with the
interaction with exogenous antigen and
this interaction happens via the
membrane bound antibody molecule on the
B cell
b-cell receptor mediated endocytosis
leads to
this first step the presentation of the
antigen on Class 2 MHC molecule B cells
are also professional antigen presenter
so they can display the substances on
Class 2 MHC the display is antigen to T
helper cell T helper cell interacts with
the B cell at several levels first of
all the TCR and mhc2 interaction leads
to the first signal for B Cell
Activation and the second signal for B
Cell Activation comes from the cd40
receptor
and cd40 ligand on the T helper cell so
these two interaction give rise to the
necessary signals
for B Cell Activation so this method is
known as th dependent B Cell Activation
because it involves T helper cell but
there are also methods like
T independent B Cell Activation where
several antigen crosslinks B cell
receptor and that leads to the potent
signal for B Cell Activation let me
explain this in bit more details many a
times bacteria secretes flagellin or
let's say LPS these kind of antigens
which can cross link The receptors
and this is the trigger for B Cell
Activation
so cross linking is the critical factor
which leads to the receptor activation
but this is much less potent and this
many of the cases this does not lead to
subsequent uh changes
anyway
when B cell is activated B cell would
re-enter the cell cycle they would
proliferate and make more B cells
generally when B cell did not encounter
any antigens they are known as naive B
cells it has membrane bound IGM or igd
when it interacts with T cell and the
antigen on the T cells so they
ultimately become
activated and differentiated into a
antibody secretary plasma cells plasma
cells are actually differentiated format
of B cells the naive B cell can become
different type of plasma cells which
might give rise to different isotypes of
the antibodies
now this is done by a process known as
isotype switching reaction or class
switching recombination if you want to
learn more about that there is a
dedicated video on that part but for now
if you need more nodes flash cards Etc
you can go to my Facebook page or in the
Instagram page link is in the
description feel free to support our
Channel via paytm PayPal or UPI see you
in next video